this right here is a picture of an
Airbus a380 aircraft and I was curious
how long would it take this aircraft to
take off and I looked up its takeoff
velocity so take take off velocity and
the specs I got were 280 kilometers per
hour and to make this a velocity we have
to specify a direction as well not just
a magnitude so the direction is in the
direction of the runway this that would
be the positive direction right over
there so we're when we're talking about
acceleration or velocity and this we're
going to assume it's in this direction
the direction of going down the runway
and I also looked up its specs and this
I'm simplifying it a little bit because
it's not going to have a purely constant
acceleration but let's just say from the
moment that the pilot says we're taking
off to when it actually takes off it has
a constant acceleration its engines are
able to provide a constant acceleration
acceleration acceleration of 1.0 m/s per
second so after every second it can go
one meter per second faster than it was
due going at the beginning of that
second or another way to write this is
1.0 1.0 m/s per I'd it this way meters
per second per second can also be
written as meters per second squared I
find this a little bit more intuitive
this is a little bit neater to write so
let's figure this out so the first thing
that I so we're trying to answer is how
long how long does takeoff last take off
how long does takeoff last that is the
question we will try to answer and to
answer this
at least my brain wants to at least get
the unit's right so over here we have
our acceleration in terms of meters and
seconds or second squared and over here
we have our takeoff velocity in terms of
kilowatt kilometers and hours so let's
just convert this takeoff velocity into
meters per second and then it might
simplify this answering this question so
if we have 280 kilometers
per hour how do we convert that to
meters per second so let's convert it to
kilometers per second first so we want
to get rid of this hours and the best
way to do that if we have an hour in the
denominator we want an hour in the
numerator and we want it we want a
second in the denominator and so how do
what what do we multiply this by or what
are what do we put in front of the hours
in seconds so one hour in one hour there
are 3600 seconds 60 seconds in a minute
60 minutes in an hour and so you have
one of the larger unit is equal to 3600
of the smaller unit and so we can
multiply by that and if we do that the
hours will cancel out and we'll get 280
divided by 3600 kilometers per second
but I want to do all my math at once so
let's also do the conversion from
kilometers to meters so once again we
have we have kilometers in the numerator
so we want the kilometers in the
denominator now so it cancels out and we
want meters in the numerator and what's
the smaller unit it's meters and we have
1,000 meters for every one kilometer and
so when you multiply this out the
kilometers are going to cancel out and
you're going to be left with 280 280
times 1 so we don't have to write it
down times 1000 times 1000 all of that
over 3,600 all of that over 3,600 and
the unit's we have left are meters we
have meters per and the only unit we
have left here is second meters per
second so let's get my trusty ti-85 out
and actually calculate this so we have
280 times 1,000 which is obviously
280,000 but let me just divide that by
3,600 3,600 and it gives me 77.7
repeating indefinitely and it looks like
I had two significant digits in each of
these original things I had 1.0 over
here not 100% clear how many significant
digits I over here did they did was the
spec rounded to the nearest 10
kilometers or is it exactly 280
kilometers per hour just to be safe I'll
assume that it's rounded to the nearest
10 kilometers so we only have two
significant digits here so we should
only have two significant digits in our
answer so we're going to round this to
78 78 meters per second so this is going
to be this is going to be 78 meters per
second which is pretty fast in every
symbol for this thing to take off every
second that goes by it has to travel 78
meters almost three roughly 3/4 the
length of a football field in every
second but that's not what we're trying
to answer we're trying to say how long
will takeoff last well we could just do
this in our head if you think about it
the acceleration is one meter per second
per second which tells us at after every
second it's going one meter per second
faster so if you start at a velocity of
zero and then after one second we'll be
going one meter per second after two
seconds we'll be going two meters per
second after three seconds I'll be going
three meters per second so how long will
it take to get to 78 meters per second
well it'll take 78 seconds it will take
78 it'll take 78 seconds or roughly a
minute and 18 seconds and just to verify
this with our our definition of our
acceleration so to speak just remember
acceleration which is a vector quantity
in all the directions we're talking
about an hour in the direction of this
direction of the runway the acceleration
is Igor acceleration is equal to change
in velocity change in velocity over
change in time over change in time and
we're trying to solve for how much time
does it take or the change in time so
let's do that so let's multiply both
sides by change in time you get change
in time times acceleration times
acceleration is equal to change in
velocity is equal to change in velocity
and to solve for change in time divide
both sides by the acceleration so divide
both sides by the acceleration you get
change in time J I could go down here
but I just want to use all this real
estate I over here have change in time
is equal to change in velocity
change in velocity divided by
acceleration divided by acceleration and
in this situation what is our change in
velocity well we're starting off with
the velocity or assuming we're starting
off with the velocity of zero meters per
second and we're getting up to 78 meters
per second so our change in velocity is
the 78 meters per second so our change
in velocity is it is 70 so this is equal
in our situation seventy eight meters
per second is our change in velocity I'm
taking the final velocity 78 meters per
second and subtract from that the
initial velocity which is zero meters
per second and you just get this divided
by the acceleration divided by one meter
per second per second or one meter per
second squared so the numbers part are
pretty easy you have 78 divided by 1
which is just 78 and then the unit's you
have meters per second and then if you
divide by meters per second squared
that's the same thing as multiplying by
second squared per meter right divided
dividing by something is the same thing
as multiplying by its reciprocal and you
can do the same thing with units and
then we see the meters cancel out and
then second squared divided by seconds
you're left just left with seconds so
once again we get 78 seconds a little
over a minute for this thing to take off